spending cuts printing money and exports
have all failed to revive the world
economy in the long term we will find
out how the global economy is doing
right now and talk to Oliver locker from
Deutsche Bank research mr. Hackl how has
the divx developed in November the divx
has actually improved slightly compared
to the last month and actually when you
look at how it has improved as happen
has been a broad-based improvement from
all regions basically except for Japan
and the divx has increased so the best
level since jun 2011 oh very good news
so lately the World Trade Organization
agreed on a global trade agreement what
effects where we see that's very
questionable when we will see these
effects in general such trade agreements
are to be seen positive they're better
for allocating labour and capital across
the globe and they should actually
improve the export performance and
global growth over time but since all
these agreements still have to be
performed into law in all these regions
we will see the positive effects only
get on ok so right now we see a very
positive US economy we see growth rates
in China which part of the world is more
important for the European countries for
the euro zone what do you think we have
actually done a research piece on that
and focusing on the effects of the
Chinese growth and the US growth on
German growth but that should in general
will be also true for the European
economy and there we have to say that
the US economy is still much more
important for the European economy that
is because of title trade links tighter
financing links with a monetary system
as well as more sentiment transmission
between those continents but even so the
Chinese economy has become more
importantly especially for Germany
because China as one of the top five
exporting destinations for German
exports so if those bows regions are
improved that should be good for the
European
as well what kind of problems do is he
right now and controls like for example
France or Italy which are really quite
weak at the moment that is true I mean
in Italy you have the problem that all
those structural reforms that are
necessary to bring back stretch with
growth a long term growth are not done
currently because there are too many
difficulties on a political level still
you're a much more focused on people on
how to govern instead of actually doing
those reforms our italian economist has
looked at what trend growth actually
looks like in italy currently and that's
pretty much stagnation so the italian
government really should focus on
reforms in france it looks a bit better
structurally it's stronger currently but
even there you don't see that much
reform drive as is necessary if you look
at the president Hollande he really is
not focusing much on reforms yet because
he faces a very skeptical of a public
okay in our special talk this month we
will have a look on German politics on
the coalition treaty and on its effects
on the economy of course thank you so
far mr. Rocco so what does the coalition
treaty hold in store for Germany what
will it cost and what kind of effects
will it have on the eurozone that's what
you can find out on DW de / english /
made in germany